et cette affaire provoque des divisions
au sein même de la majorité
si l'opposition elle se retrouve unies
pour appeler jacques chirac à la
négociation
l'initiative de gilles de robien à
droite ne fait pas l'unanimité y compris
dans son propre parti et roland sicard
et philippe deslandes les sans papiers
ne voulait pas manquer le rendez-vous un
entretien dans un palais officiels il le
souhaitait depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
l'impatience était telle qu'ils étaient
un peu en avance qu'on va pas vraiment
la porte
il faut dire que si à gauche tout le
monde est d'accord pour réclamer une
négociation dans la majorité gilles de
robien est l'un des premiers à faire un
geste
résultat une heure et quart d'entretien
et à la sortie
le constat d'une situation difficile
j'ai ce sentiment aujourd'hui que ils
sont demandeurs de dialogue qu'il
comprenne la complexité de la situation
au regard de la loi française qui le
perçoivent bien que la situation de tous
dans l'église n'est pas identique et que
des solutions moduler et au cas par cas
sont sont à rechercher seulement gilles
de robien par est isolé à l'udf
certaines critiques quant au rpr et au
gouvernement ils font bloc autour de
jean louis debré jean louis debré il a
le devoir impérieux de faire ce que l'on
attend lui c'est à dire son travail de
ministre
donc je le soutiens tout à fait puis je
crois qu'il ne faut pas se laisser
déborder par ceux qui en mal de cause
ont décidé d'utiliser ces pauvres sans
papiers comme une chaire à canon
politique
il y a eu une majorité de députés et de
sénateurs qui ont voté des lois
ces lois s'appliquent le gouvernement ne
peut pas transgresser à cela ou alors il
n'est plus digne de ce nom
en tout cas la réception des
sans-papiers à l'assemblée montre bien
que la sphère se déplace sur le terrain
politique entre une gauche qui mobilise
et une majorité qui se divise le
gouvernement doit trouver une solution
et alain juppé est rentré en fin d'après
midi à paris un peu plus tôt que prévu